23 juin 2010 aéro par jean lesage de
québec
sept personnes dont deux pilotes montent
à bord d'un avion taxi propriété
d'aéropro une minute après son décollage
éric thiboutot a été pilote pour la
compagnie d'avions taxis aéropro pour
lui l'écrasement de cet avion est une
catastrophe annoncée
transports canada des d'aussi énorme sur
le code aéropro c'était prévisible
c'est ce que plus chacun après cet
écrasement qui a fait sept morts
la compagnie fait l'objet d'une enquête
exhaustive de transports canada ils
n'ont elles ont tombé beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup d'âme à aéropro perd son
certificat d'exploitation
le propriétaire aurèle labbé ne peut
plus faire voler ses avions
mais pas pour longtemps car ils se
portent ensuite acquéreur d'une autre
compagnie street air basée au labrador
transports canada lui accorde donc un
autre certificat
qu'est-ce que transports canada aurait
dû fin aurait dû le fermer
définitivement
marc perrault enquêter sur des centaines
d'accidents pour le bureau de la
sécurité des transports du canada
transports canada un des mandats
du moins quand moi j'en qu'était un
élément de transports canada se
promouvoir l'aviation civile c'est à
dire ce n'est pas de leur fait les
permis dans un courriel
transports canada justifie ce certificat
en nous disant que twitter un cadre de
gestion différent de celui qui existait
chez aéropro
c'est pourtant le même propriétaire qui
est derrière les deux compagnies c'est
inacceptable de l'apport de transports
canada d'accepter des choses comme ça
henri labbé n'a pas voulu nous
rencontrer mais au téléphone il s'est
montré plutôt fier de son coup moi je
trouve ça extrêmement scandaleux parce
que ça détruit des vies s'est dit rooney
carrière cette schümann des passagers
nous avions plusieurs questions pour le
ministre fédéral des transports marc
garneau mais il a décliné notre demande
d'entre eux
ici françois dallaire et au canada
montréal